along the Gulf Coast tornadoes touched
down
and intense hail fell while flooding
continues to cause significant damage in
the midwest along the Florida Panhandle
Thursday residents faced a daunting
cleanup after a twister hit hashford a
small town west of Tallahassee it peeled
off roofs snap trees and tossed debris
destruction can be seen for miles it is
hailing like crazy the hail's so intense
and large this driver in Panama City
Beach had to pull off the road
the hail part of a brutal week of severe
weather where on Wednesday it stretched
over a thousand miles from Richmond Hill
a Savannah Georgia suburb
Central Texas where large hailstones
sent livestock running for cover as it
pelted this pool